[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome once again to I'd like
to know our Bible question and answer
program one of our favorite programs
here at Seafood until in some TV because
it gives us an opportunity to hear from
you to see what's on your mind and in
your heart and to answer your questions
from the word of God my name is CA
Murray I am an associate speaker and
media consultant here at Secrets
unsealed and some TV and I'm in the
president the president in the presence
of our founder and present president
president of having trouble with
president today and and I can say this
principal speaker Pastor Stephen Moore
pastor always good to have you here it's
always good to have you too CA
good to share the word of God we've got
a lot of questions and we've got a very
exciting program we have questions
coming in from I saw Kenya I saw Dallas
I think I saw another country in Africa
and some other countries so we've got
some good questions coming to us from
around the world we make you this pledge
weekly that we will answer your
questions if we can if they can be
answered from the word of God we are so
close to the coming of the Lord you
don't need to hear man's opinion you
need to hear a word from the Lord so we
will give you that word from the Lord if
a word from the Lord can indeed be found
we will find it from the word of God and
give you that answer should you like to
get in on the fun and we invite you to
do so write us please at TV at sumtv.org
that address again is TV at some
tv.org and we will get to your questions
as soon as we possibly can the list is
rather long and we are happy about that
better to have too many questions and
not enough
but it takes us a while to get through
them because we don't like to rush
through your questions we want to take
our time with them and give due
diligence to each question so that you
don't feel shortchanged or cheated when
you write in so we will do that we'll
get it to you as soon as we can uh by
the grace of God Pastor if you would
have prayer for us then we'll get
started and I can toss this first
question at you yeah before I have a
word of prayer I'd just like to mention
that some people have said why don't you
have a Live question and answer program
and the reason is that some questions we
have to do research you know we could do
it off the cuff uh answer yes to
questions but we would like to do it
thoroughly and so when we have the
question sent in electronically we have
an opportunity to do the research and
provide a better answer yeah yeah and
that's very important because you can
just sort of do it on the fly but I know
you are a man of research and you've
infected all of us with that research
mindset so we do like to go to the word
and get as deep and thorough an answer
as possible so that we're doing uh
justice to the questions uh very good
thought let's pray Father in Heaven as
we come for this program today we
realize that our knowledge and wisdom is
so limited compared to yours and that's
why we come to you to ask that you will
be with us that you will Enlighten our
minds and you will help us to answer
these questions which uh the the
Watchers of our program
have concerns about so guide us and I
ask that those who are watching might be
blessed we pray in Jesus name amen amen
and amen this first question
comes to us from Elizabeth in Dallas
Texas we have recently returned from
Dallas to from our spring anchor a very
fine time uh baptized a New Soul into
the church that wanted you to baptize
him Paul and just a wonderful time so
this is coming from uh Dallas it's been
here a little while so it didn't come as
a result of our of our of our going uh
this came this
um dear pastors
this is kind of lengthy but I'll try to
get to it quickly First Kings 14 31 and
15 chapter 15 verses one and two it
states that after rehoboam died his son
reigned and that he reigned three years
in Jerusalem his mother's name was
mayaka the daughter of Absalom actually
his granddaughter I do believe
in second chronicles 12 16 and chapter
13 verses one and two it states that
King died his son abijah rain three
years in Jerusalem and his mother name
was Micaiah the daughter of Uriel of
gibea however in First Kings abayam's
heart was not perfect towards the Lord
as the heart of David his father however
in second chronicles about his heart was
right with the Lord is by him and about
her the same person
please note that she's reading from the
King James and um uh are these two
individuals the same individual what say
you brother pastor
it's the same individuals they are um
it's just a difference in spelling uh in
the in the names uh I might say
something that goes perhaps Beyond
responding to this question and that is
that in the Bible individuals are named
by different names let me just give you
some examples uh the father of Kish
is called abiel yes uh in first Samuel 9
verse 1 but he's called the son of Nair
in Jeremiah chapter 24 and verse
actually First Chronicles 8 33. then you
have also jeconiah
is referred to as jehoiakim in Second
Kings 24 verse 6. Matthew uh in Matthew
9 verse 9 is called Levi in Mark chapter
2 and verse 14. uh Peter was also called
Simon and labias was also called
Thaddeus in Matthew chapter 10 verses 2
and 3. so individuals have different
names so even if the name was slightly
different yes it can be the same person
can be also a phenomenon that happens in
the Bible is sometimes a grandfather is
called a father very true in the sense
of ancestor so when it uses the word
father and it's really a grandfather it
means an ancestor one example of that is
Daniel chapter 5 and verse 18. yes where
it speaks about uh your father
Nebuchadnezzar well he was actually uh
belshazzo's grandfather and so we need
to take all of that into account when we
look at different names I also would
like to mention that there seems to be
discrepancies between Second Kings and
second chronic first and second Kings
and first and second Chronicles when it
comes to the chronology uh the the
specific beginning of the regional year
and the number of years that each
reigned the reason for that is because
in one case you have the accession year
counted and in the another case you
don't have the accession year counted I
would recommend a book that was written
by an expert in the field recognized uh
worldwide he's a Seventh-Day Adventist
he died a few years ago his name is
Edwin thiely and he wrote a book called
The Mysterious numbers of the Hebrew
Kings where he coordinates beautifully
all of the chronology in first and
second uh Kings and first first and
second chronicles and and I think that's
true sometimes you go about nicknames
other than we do we do it too your name
is is Stephen Bohr Pastor Stephen Bohr I
have taken a calling you Rabbi and
I notice it's spreading
so if you hear somebody say Rabbi
they're talking about past divorce same
guy
should I tell them what I call you no
you're talking about um
a buyer and being a good or a bad king
um so many of the the kings of Judah is
there were bad kings and and he was one
ASA his son you know they were they were
and his dad you had three pretty bad
guys
um
he he made one just statement uh at one
time in his life uh when they were
talking about fighting he says do not
fight against God your father for you
will not succeed that's a writing
statement even even righteous
unrighteous people can every now and
again say something that is true you
know someone said uh the other day I've
heard it many times even a a stopped
watches twice is right twice a day you
know so he may say something right but
it doesn't look at the Ark of his life
you know um
so um he had a time when he when he made
a couple of true statements but he was
not in general a good King no or his
neither was his father nor his son and
so many of the Kings of Israel were not
we're not good Kings and it all depends
on the stage of the life that you're
talking about precisely because David
has called a man after God's heart but
uh he certainly wasn't a man after God's
heart when he committed adultery with
Bathsheba precisely uh yeah so uh so you
know it depends on which stage of the
life of the person you're talking about
and in this case uh in a certain stage
of his life or maybe as you mentioned
what he said uh you know he was uh he
was on the right track but then in other
stages of his life he wasn't he wasn't
yeah yeah
which is why I'm so glad that God judges
Us by the video and not the snapshot
because if you take a snapshot a picture
any one point in time it may not be too
flattering right if you take the video
they take the whole Arc of someone's
life admit you may come out with a
different picture that's correct praise
the Lord
well done Pastor
um
this one comes from Kenya I've had the
approach of being there preaching in the
union office there in Kenya
um and talking with our brothers and
sisters there
um
his name is cando wanguo that's the best
I can do with that praise the Lord he
says I'm a Kenyan citizen came to know
you through local gospel TV station
called end time TV and I'm not familiar
with that I don't know if that's
Adventist or not but if it is not
Adventist and we're on there we'll
praise the Lord amen if if it is
adventism around there we'll praise the
Lord anyway
praise the Lord for both both occasions
though though he is not an Adventist
um I truly honestly love and follow your
teachings and preachings even on YouTube
well praise the Lord
um amen hopefully you will be impressed
to join up with the Brethren one day and
become a member of The Seventh-Day
Adventist Church
he wants to the answers he wants us to
explain the difference between Rapture
and second coming and the correct order
of events as in the Book of Revelation
and Daniel I pray that our father will
give you good wisdom his spirit and
strength to continue ministering the
Gospel of Jesus
um
of Jesus Christ and is looking forward
to hearing from us so we praise the Lord
for that your Kenyan brother well the
the offhand answer is Rapture means
caught up is not in the Bible
Second Coming
is Christ coming to get his children
that is in the Bible
That's the the sort of quick quick
answer if we look at first first
Thessalonians 4 we get the order for the
Lord himself shall descend from the hand
of the Shout with the voice of the
Archangel and Trump of God a dead and
cross of Rise first then we which are
alive and remain shall be caught up
together with them the crowds to meet
the Lord in the air so shall we ever be
with the Lord there is your order there
is your sequence the Rapture and maybe
you can talk a little bit about this
because you talked about this just
several days ago is not a Biblical
concept
yeah basically this individual is not a
Seventh-Day Adventist and I get the
impression that I get is that uh he's
heard that there's a difference between
the Rapture and the second coming yes uh
in the Evangelical World The Rapture
takes place seven years before the
Glorious coming of Christ in their minds
and they use several Arguments for that
I won't get into them the 70 weeks and
one taken one left
Etc but really in the Bible There's no
distinction between uh the Rapture and
the second coming the word rapture
simply means caught up so in first
Thessalonians chapter four where it says
that that the righteous living and dead
are going to be caught up to meet the
Lord in the air uh you know that is uh
that is the second coming of Christ
there's only one second coming of Christ
there's not two stages to the second
coming I'd like to recommend uh you know
maybe some materials here for I'm going
to call him JK because he gave us the
initials of his name much easier than
one ghoul so anyway we have we have this
little book called taken or left which
is one of the arguments that those who
believe in the Rapture use that seven
years before the Glorious coming there's
going to be a group that are ready and
are going to be taken yes and all of the
other ones are going to be left behind
yeah which is the title of a series that
was produced a few years ago so this
little book deals with one shall be
taken the other left and also I have
this uh study notes the prophetic
panorama which is available online for
free you know if you go to our website
secrets unsealed.org to resources you'll
find this and you can read it online
this deals with all of the arguments
that are used by people who believe in a
Rapture of the church seven years before
the glory is coming I don't know of a
single argument that that I don't deal
with in this study notes so I would
recommend that JK
um you know get a copy of this book
taken or left a small book only 32 pages
and also a copy of this study notes you
don't have to purchase it from us it's
available online
so basically
there is no difference between the
Rapture and the second coming both of
them take place at the same time at the
Glorious coming of Jesus Christ in power
and Glory yes well said I like the
32-page one uh it's for it's concise and
precise and you can get through the the
doctrinal premise very quickly I would I
would encourage JK to when you're
thinking about this when you look when
you look at it look at the history of
the word taken uh
the theory seems to to suggest that
you're taken to heaven but if you look
at the history of Taken it's always
taken away in destruction uh and that's
the the bub and and for a time you know
I wrestled with this but if you study it
out prayerfully uh you'll come to the
right conclusion that taken is is not
taken to Heaven it's taken to
destruction yeah the the word left is a
Remnant word
for example if a flood comes we'll say
did it take everyone away wasn't anyone
left yeah you know the word left is a
Remnant word uh Genesis 7 verse 23 says
only Noah and his family were left well
they're the ones that survived they were
not the ones who were destroyed and
those are only two examples that we find
multiple examples in the Bible that
those who are taken are really overtaken
by the enemy they're destroyed precisely
whereas those who are left are are those
who remain another example is Isaiah
Chapter 4 verses two and three where it
says that those who remain or those who
are left Shall be Called holy yeah
obviously they're not the wicked another
thing the reason why
um
conservative Protestants evangelicals as
they're called believe in two stages to
the second coming is because they have
the timing of the Millennium wrong see
Jesus made two promises to his faithful
disciples One Promise was that he was
going to come and take him to the
father's house yes that would be heaven
the other promise that he made is the
meek are going to inherit the earth so
how can Jesus fulfill both of those
promises to take us to heaven to the
father's house and then also the meek
will inherit the earth well those who
believe in the raptures believe that
there's only one way that that can
happen and that is that Jesus is going
to take faithful to heaven for seven
years and then he's going to come back
and he's going to establish his kingdom
here and the meek will inherit the Earth
but the biblical Reckoning or way of
understanding it is that Jesus will come
the second time he will take his people
to heaven for a thousand years that way
you'll fulfill the promise to take us to
his father's house right and then after
the thousand years he will return make a
new heavens and new earth and the meek
will inherit the earth yes that is the
biblical way of of explaining how Jesus
can fulfill the promise to take us to
his father's house and on the other hand
the promise that the meek will inherit
the earth yes yes and so much of it is
based on the the the 70 weeks prophecy
they take 69 weeks and put it here and
then take that one week and put it all
the way over to the end and they
separate what is a a a joined prophecy
it's 70 weeks in total not 69 and in one
way over here uh at the end of time so
it just doesn't it doesn't work there's
no example in the Bible of a gap right
in a prophetic sequence you know it's if
it's 70 weeks it's 70 consecutive weeks
precisely it's not 69 then 2000 years
plus yeah and then the 70th week is
fulfilled there's no example in the
Bible of such Reckoning of Bible
prophecy precisely what's that good
question and good answer thank you
Pastor
um let's see is this next on Dr Cox
yes all right let's see
um
he wants to ask this question and give a
reason uh you can we can simplify but
we'll just ask it as as he as he gave it
there is a deception running through our
denomination and from it arises some
questions I will not give my opinion but
leave it to yourself to answer from the
word of God
here's the first one
when the Israelites walked around the
walls of Jericho did they also walk
around on the Sabbath this is the
question I have all I am often asked
and question two which flows out of
question one was Israel ever forbidden
excuse me to fight or defend itself
on the Sabbath all right so we have to
go to Joshua 6 to to deal with this
where we find the the the story of the
Jericho experience
question one is what
this deception is trying to use to
support for a lunar Sabbath or whatever
uh else they are believing and it's
interesting because just last week
several days ago I heard you give an
excellent explanation of the lunar
Sabbath what it is what it is not uh why
it is why it is not so
um let me toss this to your great kind
self uh to sort of work with this
um so let's go to let me catch you and
go back here to Joshua chapter six okay
and uh and then we'll sort of we'll sort
of wrestle with this a little bit
all right here we are
all right they walked around seven days
to walk around seven days does that not
presuppose that one of those days is
going to be seven
most likely yes
[Laughter]
that's like the Israel had the Six Day
War yeah now that you could actually get
in from you can start on Sunday and
finish on Friday and you got your six
days right
um but but not um uh if you got seven
one is gonna have to be a Sabbath yep
yeah
so they walked around one time for Six
Days on the seventh they walked around
seven the walls came down
um his question is
um did they walk around on the Sabbath
you know Sabbath activity Pastor bar as
you well know is not a day of inactivity
it was never intended to be it was
intended to be a day of change of
activity of change of focus you take
your mind off the things of the world
you disengage from the things of the
world and you focus you lock in as it
were on Sabbath uh for most pastors and
preachers Sabbath is a fairly busy day
you you work more on Sabbath than you do
uh on not when I was pastoring the
Ephesus Church
um my the pre-sabbit school started at
seven o'clock in the morning I was there
for that I lived an hour away from the
church just crossing New York City and I
didn't get home most sabbaths
10 o'clock 10 30. you know the long day
meetings meetings meetings meetings
Bible studies different kinds of things
then you're preaching also so it's a day
of increased work but it's the focus of
your work uh that's important right and
the focus as long as it's God oriented
uh and it's breaking the routine of the
week it is acceptable in the sight of
God so
I haven't been able to find anything in
the Bible about whether Israel suspended
their Wars on the Sabbath when they
entered the Promised Land
I don't know if you have but I haven't
been able to find anything about them
suspending uh What uh what they
regularly did on the Sabbath yeah
um so so I think if there's silence on
that
with regards to Jericho obviously one of
those days must have been the Sabbath
but where we cannot say with certainty
that the seventh day
when actually the walls came down right
that it was on the Sabbath the sequence
might have started on a different date
yeah we just don't know and
um you know when we get to heaven we'll
have to ask Jesus uh or when we see that
panoramic view above the holy city at
the end of the Millennium yes uh we'll
be able to see the fall of the walls of
Jericho and there's oh now we know yeah
yeah if they started on a Wednesday they
would cross a Sabbath uh so we don't we
didn't know precisely when they when
they thought when they when they began I
looked at it from a slightly different
aspect I was looking for any command to
to forbid them to to fight on Sabbath
and I I could not find any in my history
and then I sort of looked at this today
again I have never seen a command with
the Lord specifically told them uh no
don't don't fight today because it's
it's Sabbath
um so uh it's a it's a good question an
interesting question but um the evidence
is lacking for to make a difference
initiative statement and I think that's
the best we can do with that at this
point in time because it's just not
there and if it did involve a Sabbath
they were in the Lord's mission
because God had told them to march
around Jericho so even if they marched
one of the days around the city they
were not disobeying God because God was
the one who gave them the command to
circle the city yes and even if the the
walls of the city fell on The
Seventh-Day Sabbath
still they would not be guilty in the
sign of God because God was the one who
told them when to start marching around
the city and how many days to March
around the city and they were on God's
mission in other words the the
the people in Jericho dug their heels in
yes they said we're not going to let you
come into the promised land and God said
okay then you're going to you're going
to destroy the city of Jericho yes so
they were really on a mission for God
and the destruction of Jericho of course
was done by God yes uh so if it was done
in the seventh day and God was the one
who who caved in the walls of Jericho
well God was in perfect harmony with the
people praise the Lord and the people
with God one one Sabbath says quickly
um my first Elder uh when I was passed
in the Freeport church he lives in
Brooklyn his house burned that Friday
night and we had Sabbath School I got
word we suspended service worship
service I told her to go home let's meet
back here let's go and and help the
other we spent the rest of the Sabbath
digging through rubble and trying to
establish what we could and of course it
was a great Testament to his neighbors
who who knew he was Adventist that his
actually come out and help it was a
lawful to do good on the Sabbath you
know sure so we worked hard we were
sweated ladies made food and all kind of
stuff we stayed there till after dark
but it was a good witness to those
neighbors around that we weren't so
Heavenly minded that we were no earthly
good we would help one of our brothers
uh on the Sabbath day yeah there's a
later question that we have where
another Sabbath issue is involved
where normally uh what the people what
what the person who asked the question
uh said that they whether they should do
this on the Sabbath or not you regularly
would not do it yes but if it if it
involves helping other people doing good
on the Sabbath it is lawful to do good
on the Sabbath then I think that it
would be acceptable God takes into
account
the motive that drives the ACT
and when the ACT is totally other
focused on the Sabbath
and really you can't do it after the
Sabbath yes uh then a God allows doing
good on the holy Sabbath even though it
involves things that regularly uh you
would do it during the week yeah yeah I
remember years ago when I was on a
general conference committee
um some material came in about we were
asked to make a decision about certain
activities in Adventist hospitals on
Sabbath
um and they were saying we're not going
to do elective surgeries on Sabbath but
if somebody comes in from a car accident
or something we're going to say well
you're going to stay till here until
Sunday because we can't touch you today
no you deal with it right then right
because you've got an emergency
situation which we often call maybe a
little Cavalier Ox in a ditch because
Christ said you know if your Ox Falls in
a ditch on the Sabbath you're going to
go get him out you know right stay there
until Sunday no you get him out right
then so if you have an emergency
situation it is lawful to do good to
help somebody on the Sabbath day and and
even if it's something that you could
wait till after this Sabbath to do but
the person is suffering during the
Sabbath you still do it like the man who
had the Wither withered hand yes he
wasn't going to die on the Sabbath yes
and yet he was suffering on the Sabbath
because he had a withered hand so Jesus
says hey if somebody's suffering on the
Sabbath and you can help him go ahead
and help the quality of life as you
praise the Lord praise the Lord so it is
indeed lawful to do good on the Sabbath
day uh we've had a good time answering
your questions hopefully we have uh
answered them sufficiently and thank you
again for sending them remember TV at
some
tv.org our time has fast slipped into
eternity allow us in closing to wish you
both Grace and peace through our Lord
and Savages Christ we'll see you again
soon bye bye and God bless
[Music]
thank you
foreign